[Music]
foreign
15 here on a Friday morning so picture
this you go to the Las Vegas Strip you
go to sit down at a table the dealer
deals you your cards that's pretty
commonplace of course but the 1950s it
wasn't a possibility for everyone but a
black dentist from the south fought and
was successful at desegregating the
strip our Candace Charles shares the
Amazing Story of James B McMillan
it's really an impact every morning
Treyon Boone passes this picture on the
way to class at James B McMillan
Elementary Nikki Longmore is the
principal she says she hopes the man on
the wall reminds students that they do
have the ability to make change and to
make a difference in our community prior
to having a school named after him in
the 50s McMillan moved from the Jim Crow
South to Las Vegas where he was the
first black dentist we're looking at a
very segregated Las Vegas that very much
mimicked the Wild Wild West the
president of NAACP Las Vegas Quentin
Savoie says black families were
relegated to the West Side Dr McMillan
would build his dental practice here and
begin his fight for civil liberties
becoming the president of the NAACP Las
Vegas chapter in 1960. there is a
national protest that was occurring and
that Las Vegas needed to address its own
history of segregation and racism unlv's
African-American associate professor
Tyler Perry tells me it was the then
that his fight would go beyond west side
to the strip in the 50s and 60s blacks
could only enter the strip through the
back of the house greats like Sammy
Davis Jr and Nat King Cole could perform
but couldn't stay or enjoy the hotels or
casinos so they could work there but
they couldn't be seen or could they be
heard McMillan took action announcing
that 300 people were protests on the
Strip even though Las Vegas was by any
objective measure a pretty racist place
that was still bad for business at that
time he had to be a courageous leader
his courage led to what is now known as
the Moulin Rouge agreement signed in
1960 at the iconic Moulin Rouge The only
integrated casino at the time it
guarantees that black people can enter
into strip casinos and not be harassed
or thrown out regardless of whatever
occurs after 1960
it is just completely true that one must
respect the fact that James was willing
to go the distance and Paving
leaders I hope I walk in his footsteps
Candace Charles 8 News Now
James B McMillan fought against
injustices in our community for the rest
of his life he helped create what would
become the urban Chamber of Commerce in
Las Vegas he passed away in 1999 he was
82 years old